- Robert Durst, the millionaire
who was the subject of
the documentary "The Jinx"
was found guilty of murder, finally.
A California jury found Durst guilty
of the murder of Susan Berman,
who was going to tell the police
how she helped Durst cover
up a different murder.
She was shot in the back of the head
before she could testify.
And Robert Durst was found
guilty of that murder
and believe it or not,
the tapes from "The Jinx"
played a crucial role
in convicting Durst.
After filmmaker Andrew Jarecki
turned those tapes over to the LAPD,
they issued an arrest warrant
and arrested Durst in 2015
and he has now been found guilty.
You might recall that Durst was
acquitted of the 2001 murder
of Morris Black, his neighbor,
though Durst admitted
to dismembering the body
and disposing of it.
Durst will serve a mandatory
life sentence in prison
and he's not going to
get out anytime soon.